what do I think you should be expanding
or declining in things you like the most
second can be the things that make most
business sense if you don't like it and
you're doing it because it's the money
you fall into what people lost money on
nfts people lost money on cannabis
people lost money on fashion brands
people chase the thing they think the
money's in but they don't actually like
it or like it enough three things you're
good at or the people you have over and
under expansion comes from two things
the subjective opinion and strategy of
the founder and
number two the capacity of that founder
to build family yeah right and when I
say build family I mean you know
you've gone too fast
either because
you're defining that as the things that
have worked or not worked you're
defining that thank you so much Joe
you're defining that based on
um
how you feel about your leadership right
if you're feeling amazing about her well
then you're like oh the campaign agency
is good if you're not feeling great
about and what he's doing over here then
then it's not going well so for a lot of
us in this room in different like what I
like about this format is sometimes the
advice hits for everyone every single
person in this room's 100 variable of
how much they could expand is completely
predicated on their relationship with
the people that are leading those
subdivisions those projects those
companies those offices and this is why
I spend so much time talking about the
people Dynamics
so you know if I go back to that time or
if I'm thinking about today
it's a very similar game which is
a how do I sit with people watch this
how long have you been here great yeah
11 years all right yeah two yep James
dust all right yeah let's keep it on
memo eight and a half right like and
there's obviously newer like Europe but
like that's a lot of eight nine tens
yeah that's a lot and by agency
standards across this whole company it's
a part of why because we really do focus
on the relationship part of the people
that work here and at Ebbs and flows
when I look at all of them there's been
different times when they've been overly
busy sometimes not as busy like what I'm
very good at is somebody was talking to
me the other day who's been here for
nine years and literally saying they
feel guilty because they don't feel like
they've been productive for the last
three
and I said that has a lot to do with the
way your first six booked
five of your first six you worked way
too crazy you were hungry we were close
enough that you were feeling you didn't
even realize we were working that much
because it just felt fun and I'm like
and then covet happened and then
differently you know and again like
again you know ironically actually Jesse
Joe Maribel James Bay ball worked at
vaynermedia before Sasha those are
different speeds different things
they've had different roles you know
we've talked about that we're like
there's so many different things going
on so I think a couple things one to
answer you directly what do you like
doing the most is a very good like if
you're going into notes mode number one
what what do I think you should be
expanding or declining in things you
like the most
you personally the things you like the
most
second can be the things that make most
business sense almost everyone starts
with business sense where's the most
money where's the most opportunity to me
I think that's important
when it's a human all of the sizes that
our companies are if you don't like it
and you're doing it because it's the
money you fall into what people lost
money on nfts people lost money on on
cannabis people lost money on fashion
brands people keep chasing the thing
people lose money on social media when
they expand it like people chase the
thing they think the money's in but they
don't actually like it or like it enough
so things you like the most
number two things where you see the
business opportunity it's still
important to know the addressable market
and how good is the opportunity three
things you're good at or the people you
have that are good or the people you
have right like one of the things that's
very obvious to me is most leaders when
they start to expand hire someone they
think is good at the thing but they
themselves are not good at the thing
killer crushes people right because they
don't even know how to judge the thing
so those things stand out for me
tremendously
early on in the first three four years
of Vayner I was very good at training up
people then for five or six years I got
away from it because I was thinking
about not that I would not that I cared
any less about it I felt a couple things
happened there was enough people around
to do osmosis plus I was trying to learn
other things and bringing in other
capabilities
I'm like wait a minute we're not good at
social media
not like you're not good at social media
I mean by my standards that there was a
big Delta
that's exactly the thing we were growing
but we were growing because we're
competing with a world that's really bad
at social media and I realized that the
Delta between me and the companies was
so great I've even you know as James
knows for the last year and Sasha team
one big thing right now is that Vayner
over covid for three years really got
its [__] together and now I'm like hey
Sasha I want to get our [__] together
like so you know one thing you need to
do is a couple things don't get crippled
by the company not being as good at the
craft As You Are
figure out how good the company is at
the craft compared to the other things
that companies could hire
I wasn't judging vaynermedia against
garyvee I was judging vaynermedia
against droga 5 against social code
against its competitive set sometimes a
Founder has ego wrapped up in their own
capabilities and it cripples them
because they think the machine is not
executing to their level
but you're but you're not comparing the
machine compared to the other machines
you know there's a really good chance
that I'm one of the true best people at
social media like a lot of data supports
that I can't expect 2 000 people to be
doing it as well plus this plus they
can't do it as well the clients aren't
letting us right so there's a lot of
that right so so I think I think that's
a framework that you need to get
comfortable with
don't compare it against what you want
the work quality to be compared against
the Alternatives of what they could be
doing with that same money and that
always gave me peace of mind because boy
oh boy are people really bad at social
media as agencies and especially
creative agencies trying to do it and
even like Standalone social media
agencies really the truth is the people
that are really good at it are doing it
for themselves not doing it for clients
I was weird in that I had a crazy big
Vision that I was like I felt that I
could do both and I ended up being right
but
even in my earliest days I'm like why
don't you just do this for myself but I
knew that I wanted to build this massive
machine mainly on the back that I knew I
was going to have relationships with
people for a long time and felt I could
I think the biggest vulnerability is
that the as everybody on Earth that
doesn't live in this exact City
has a has a feeling that they're not
like even in the like even like even big
places like San Francisco and L.A and
Chicago have inferiority complex to New
York that's America you start getting
into places like I get a hundred emails
a year I'm the third biggest in Poland
but it sucks I'm feel scared too small
and I'm like and I always try to tell
those again I'm excited to tell you this
until you have [__] 50 market share
of Austria yeah don't talk to me about
this place is too small yeah you know
people love to say my country's too
small Gary I'm like you do
.0001 of the business in your country
and so they get so fixated on the
ideology that they're in a smaller
country without realizing like you could
do 20 times more business you should
focus on the most profitable product you
can sell to People based on the
realities of the budget in your
Marketplace that is also something you
feel good about yeah if you can't create
a business it's why the Sasha group
exists your question is actually
answered in The Meta of us even being in
this room yeah two so many people were
coming to vaynermedia that looked more
like us because I'm us much more than
Pepsi and Starbucks that I was like
we're saying no to everybody because I
couldn't make the math work
okay cool thanks for reaching out do you
have 500 000 a year minimum to get out
of bed all of you are like no I'll keep
watching your videos
and then my brain's like this is stupid
like let's figure out how to create a
company that does provide value for five
thousand bucks or 50 000 bucks or a
hundred thousand bucks and so we built
something from from scratch you could do
the same thing your fourth company could
be the one that actually is more in tune
with the actual budgets of Austria or
you can expand your services to Germany
which is a much bigger Market you could
yeah it just depends on you yeah I keep
going back to people because the reason
you're not in Germany in a big way
competing at the highest levels is you
need teammates that can hold it down in
Germany or you need to move to Germany I
don't know but those become the real
options make sense absolutely so it's
one of two you either understand okay I
need to build family and then I feel
comfortable sending someone to Germany
because you can't keep you can't have a
lot I learned a lot of great things in
my dad's store like the people who were
at the register you needed to kind of
trust right so right so if you're gonna
[__] open an office in Germany the
reason you have it or I haven't is I
don't have the per you know one of the
things I keep trying to build scale like
memorable doesn't even notice I'm like
the other day in a meeting literally
this is real talk I said to Marcus I'm
like you think Maribel would leave
America because we're thinking about
expansion and this is like real I know
I'm funny and I say personal stuff out
loud I'm sorry but did they reach out to
you already yeah right you know right
James knows that everyone's in play at
every moment he's happy to hold on to
you as long as possible yeah
right they talk to you right remember
well they did right yeah Market they're
like these are like so why because I
know I'm family with Maribel we've I she
was close to me when she worked in
proper Vayner for three years then she
worked directly for me in the office
here we really got close during that
time we talk we we talk now the way I
talk to like Brandon or my mom I don't
talk to her every day but we're talking
even looks in the office that lets me
say
would Maribel move to Colombia like like
these are like real things you can say
to yourself that are real you can't do
that if you don't have family I can't do
that we haven't had the time for me to
be able to do that with you know like
you know what I mean but you know but he
did go to Tennessee yeah like from New
York like grew up in Jersey like in New
York and we're like we're opening up and
he actually went for how long four seven
years seven yeah you know like
this is why everyone here is completely
limited yeah completely based on how
much they build family yeah
family
you can't grow because you're too scared
you're too smart you won't take the risk
because you don't know you know you
won't know who that person is so what I
would do right now for every business
here is build as many teammates that are
forever as possible from day one
hire a kid off the street for 12 bucks
an hour like to be like make it like be
like you want to be here for uh San
Francisco 20 bucks an hour like to you
know to you know you you
from and you know this some of you know
this you know like I'm weird day one I'm
like you're gonna be here forever I'm
like I know you don't know how to answer
that yet but do you want to be are you
that kind of person if you don't want to
be that's amazing I'm not trying to get
you to say yes I'm just trying to get
into your mind and see what kind like
and so and you know what happens after
time is then people start seeing things
happen people saw him go and be a leader
and Echo people saw these all go to
Sasha and people saw Nate and trouty who
were like inter both started his interns
become my partner in a wine brand and
people start to see things then everyone
believes you they don't believe by the
way nobody believed me at first not one
person I was like they didn't believe me
and that's okay and expect them to
believe me
but they believe me now and you that's
what you want to start building from day
one that is your limiter first of all
thank you for everything I've been
following you since 2013. humbled you've
definitely helped me navigate a lot we
have a similar story I wasn't a good
student started off in the high school
airbrushing t-shirts literally in my
grandfather's garage built a wooden
screen for the press all of that now I
love it doing executions with the
Warriors it's great it's crazy right
it's crazy I mean just from the ground
up of just doing and learning so that's
how I've always been seeing I guess my
question is around infrastructure so I I
took a step back from I used to make a
lot of content I had our in-house
manufacturing facilities did all screen
printing right across the street from
Tesla did a lot of stuff with that
realized I was miserable good for you so
in 2016 2017 I sold the manufacturer and
I went into I'm like we're more of like
a creative agencies right where we want
to you tapped into what you liked yeah
exactly and the merchandise part we
liked that but it was a piece of it it
wasn't the whole thing right you didn't
have to do that part exactly until I
realized oh we can partner got your
stuff and ever since we did that
everything kind of got better worked out
good for you and so notice how it's
started with him knowing what he liked
so many people at the table are doing
[__] they don't like but it's just still
making a million bucks they're still
doing fine it's killing people keep
going and that transition was hard
because super hard t-shirts and that's
how I made my money so it was a leap of
faith and it was hard in the first
couple years
um but we slowly built built it
um I took a step back from making
content I would do videos and stuff like
that and in 2019 I had my daughter first
kid good for you I realized like all the
content that I was putting out was to
like
kind of for validation more flexing
exactly yeah so I took a step back and I
have not put out any content anytime
built the infrastructure of the business
got it into a really good place and so
now you feel like you're ready to come
back yeah good for you oh we're looking
to launch a company called doing
everything different Media company
that's basically
all the stuff that our agency does but
from a brand standpoint so not an agency
standpoint so brand Consulting media
collaborations and products I understand
and so looking at how we want to scale
that up and I'm just wondering just and
you see a path where your personal brand
can be a lead gen to launching it and
getting Business Development that's good
and it brings some stuff to the world
because I think that from my experience
and how I grew up in the stuff that I
learned you're gonna do for people what
I did for you that's right and that's
that's a hundred percent what is a
motivated life not to mention when that
little girl grows up it's gonna be cool
for her to see her dad's content yeah my
kids are starting to get to the place
where I'm like oh my God all that [__] I
used to talk about 10 years ago was
about to become true you know
you know and it's so so it's a cool I
got you yes I think just infrastructure
right so like what do you need to pull
that off yeah and how do we just
where the Ages were we have never really
like done that internally so I'm just
wondering how you set up the different
departments like what is that really
it's somebody who there's multiple
things that you can go about a bunch of
different ways a couple things one if
I'm you you're trying to put your like
one thing that's amazing for me is I
live my life and content comes from it
like I don't I'm not really a Content
producer it's why I'm not I can be four
times bigger on Tick Tock about if I was
a full-time content producer tick tock's
such a specific platform where I can't
get away with the [__] I got away with
on Instagram and Facebook where it's
just the videos you got to kind of do it
and I don't have that time this is what
I do for a living but
but you can absolutely build up a couple
ways one going on small podcasts to
interview you is a killer it will crush
like because you're just doing it anyway
and then you're just post producing from
the content you need somebody who can do
design and video that could be one
friend or two people
right you need somebody who really cares
to know a little bit about the platforms
like you really need to know and look
everything about the site could be five
people it could be one person it's hard
to find one Supernova but
to win in this game you have to produce
it so you have to make it film post
produce it make the images right so
Photoshop or final cut right like you
know you need someone who understands
the platforms the platform strategy like
knowing that green screens work or
posting three times a day or like today
you know Dustin you know this in our
thread someone in the team said Gary
we're testing using the word quit versus
the word stop is making your content do
way better we call this the S and sock
strategic organic content so good news
the best part about starting now versus
three years ago organic content's back
you're one Tick Tock away one instagram
away right so you know three years ago
this hard you know build followers and
be like [__] that's a grind get a pay
ads now your content can be seen and can
explode on one post harder I was yelling
and screaming about tick tock four years
ago now it's supply and demand it's
harder but YouTube shorts you know
Facebook Facebook reels is incredible
YouTube shorts they're going to go
through a lot of this over the weekend
what I would say is for you personally
based on me making some assumptions the
size of the business
kids that you're putting on at minimum
wage
that actually care about making this
content
every small business needs to drive down
the cost of creative for me the way you
drive down the cost of creative is you
put kids on who are thrilled to get paid
minimum wage not kids who are like [__]
you there's groups that are thrilled
there's groups that are [__] you you as
a business have to find the group that's
thrilled and it's always good for a
street kid because you're not worried
about them going to Stanford right you
know that you made it from the street
then you know anyone can do the same
plus so many kids want this job but it's
platform
it's creative
and then it's putting you in a position
to make output this is a big one this is
why I want you to do podcasts because it
made you make four pieces 40s this this
project exists because I want the
content
this is not Roi positive for me
it's not
but it's Roi positive when I magnified
got it same for you you're busy
so you got to figure out you know do you
want to do the office and have one
person who's an intern just film your
whole company and you're just putting
out [__] on [__] YouTube you could
yeah I think we have the
the team in place to be able to do it
right now that we're setting up it's
more so like
from a standpoint of platforms that you
use to communicate is all through text
threat is it through slack like oh with
each other yeah oh that's that's [__]
choice of like I hate structure
because I think people fall in love with
the structure over the output so our
team runs on WhatsApp okay the whole
team I mean they've got their own [__]
what else do you [__] use Asana
no no Dustin what else do you guys use
slack I don't even [__] like
speed and I always think like you got
such a small company yeah let them talk
to each other let them work and talk
how do you build that from the
standpoint because everybody's remote
like that and we went from having office
to everybody kind of all over the place
we did the team off-site recently like
that dude I'm thinking you know honestly
bro this is the biggest thing I'm
worried about is the following it is now
crystal clear to me that and we have so
many because we've grown so much that
every 24 year old that works here AKA
two years out of school been working
here for two years is super behind
people five years ago two years in
they're losing out on osmosis in the
office
and it's not even close and I'm [__]
up because I want to make it good for
them
but I know if I come down with like five
days a week in the office they're like
you are a [__] tyrant and I'm like
[__] what do I do with this [__] because
it's so crystal clear to me that the
osmosis of the office was teaching them
I mean kids are way behind like there's
some smart kids in my company that I can
see that I'm like oh [__]
like everything's a meeting now yeah it
takes you two weeks to do a meeting when
you used to be like yo can you explain
this to me okay good like so a couple
things how big are you about 20 people
you know you if I wish I had 20 because
I'd start the path on no really I wish I
had 20 because I'd start up the path of
like hey six month warning back in the
office you're not about that life let's
talk but like cool five of you or not
I'm gonna rehire those five positions
because I think at 20 it matters or you
go on Zoom full time everyone's on the
whole time you've gotta fight like I'm
thinking
everybody on the
on the stream non-meeting in Zoom so
they can talk like literally unmute and
be like yo John can you help me real
quick and they go off and like I gotta
figure out either to force back people
in seats in Serendipity or created
virtually because the non-serendipity
moments hit on slack set up a meeting
next Tuesday what the [__] next Tuesday
was two seconds yeah so
for me it's hard I have thousands and
it's like a whole corporate to do for
you at 20 you know of that 20 if they're
working like the rest of the world half
already know they want to be back
together
yes and everybody's all over the place
now especially I get it I get it I get
it I got it then put everybody at 20 I
would put everybody on a zoom if you
work nine to five you're on Zoom ninety
five in the background
try it try it for try it
um
otherwise it gets really hard
yeah Discord could be good
technology try to create osmosis this is
the real North Star
let's keep going yep
oh cool cool I just at that point I
remember the first time I ever came to
this office that James bought me here
you had people sitting in the stairway
because they couldn't get a desk yeah
okay yeah it was and like the buzz and
the osmosis
people complain about things that
they're creating for themselves like
literally Gary I'm feeling lonely might
come to the office
okay what do I do with that help me here
you're lonely but you don't want to
commute like like I'm not a genie
you know so basically and just a quick
background I started my business back in
1981 out of my parents basement I was in
the printing business type setting and
servicing other printers yep grew it to
a small uh printing business then grew
into an agency so that's kind of a short
form of yep of my trajectory and at
where I am now today and I'm looking at
all the things that are going on and you
know and talk to James about the
situation I said what is it
for me in order obviously everybody's
looking at scaling their business and
how do I get bigger and all those other
pieces but I want to know about telling
the story as it relates to social media
because I was I was really kind of
outside of it because I've been in
business for a while and I was moving
along you know making my bills and like
you know people work for me and I'm okay
I'm comfortable I go to trips I do what
I want to do you know I know it it's all
good I know I say to myself well wait a
minute now I am this point in my career
and I'm like no no either you're going
to think about when you're going to
retire or you're going to start pushing
this thing and put your foot on the
accelerator not to mention not to
mention the longer you stay out of it
the more market share you lose
there's also that part most assured so I
was very excited about this because I'm
really looking I understand about
storytelling but I want to understand if
there is a formula to that storytelling
as it relates to socialize yeah well
let's talk about what what would you
let's go even more raw what would you
like to accomplish more customers
certainly more customers
um more quality customers of course
right more quality customers but yes
more customers in order to grow the
business and then of course to scale
business of course it's just obviously
my objective too is to scale a business
for sale of course okay I mean I've
already sold a business one of my other
businesses yep before so I know what
that's like yeah people will go their
entire life and not figure yep yep um so
I know how that works and I understand
the formula of that but there's also
pieces I want to do after you know what
I mean you know Consulting and things of
that right so the bigger you build your
personal profile the more likely you can
sit on a board or consult or things of
that nature perfect there you go pink
that's it
my intuition is you need to think about
the format I did with askgaryvee and T
with garyvee your biggest strength by a
country mile is 1981.
you can't experience
right like you know it's when you think
about a world of competitive options
you one of your biggest competitive
leverage points is being in business for
40 years for yourself is being business
for 40 years yourself and that's really
hard to you know and so you know I think
a couple things where are we at with
LinkedIn anywhere yet have we even
started this journey oh yeah okay yeah
I've started one yeah
basically
out for so long my objective of using
LinkedIn was slightly different than
other people of course of course I'm
just looking to reconnect with the
thousands of people I already know okay
who can come to me and say hey pick I'm
like holy [__] I forgot about you I saw
you on LinkedIn this happens to me now
all the time of course I saw you
LinkedIn oh my God I need you for this
particular have you have you gone down
and like sat down and gone through your
phone and your email contacts and like
sat with like a beverage of your choice
for like a full day together with your
team maybe Grandma respect so
have you gone through your phone from A
to Z and gone through it and then linked
up with the people on LinkedIn only in
pieces so
straight up super I love the time of
year we're in immediately I need you to
act as if you took a personal day or
went on vacation and take an entire full
day or two a Thursday and Friday and
literally go from A to Z on your phone
and from A to Z on your Google or your
mail you know if you just type it like I
literally want you to have another tab
open and connect just connect
with every single person
on LinkedIn got it because what's going
to happen is eight to twenty percent of
those people are going to link back with
you
but all of them because you've connected
with them have a higher likelihood of
seeing your content
the essence suck
got it got it got it thanks cool I've
got just a little sidebar that everyone
here should do but that but how often
are you posting on LinkedIn
for right now we're doing three days a
week I did a little bit of research on
that they say the best days to post is
Tuesday Wednesday Thursday we try we we
kind of ping pong back and forth we did
five days a week but I noticed that his
reach decreased
um her post yes but what about net now
it's it's it's increased so one of the
things that yeah one of the things that
people make a mistake on is they're like
oh I'm getting 700 views per post now
when I was doing five days a week I was
doing 500 posts I'm like right but one
is 2500 views and one's 2100 views if
you go three times seven versus five
times five
let's just do a quick look on what
happened with net
the other thing is
what I really want for all of you is to
get to the content that does well to
inform your content going forward so I'm
less worried about how well each
individual piece goes for all of you I
want you to take more at bats to be
better at it so right now what's
happening is too many people are trying
to be cute and like higher quality less
quantity because it deep down because
it's easier like because it's work it's
hard you got other things I get it I'm
not judging but I'm trying to tell
everybody you're all trying to get
better at tennis and if you practice
five days a week instead of three days a
week you'll be better at tennis in 24
months one of the things I'm concerned
about is when people go with that model
is they're not doing enough pieces of
content to figure out the thing that's
going to work if I wasn't posting as
often I don't know if I would have
gotten into a lot of the content I got
into because I wouldn't have the
feedback loop from all the content so
what you know one of the things you all
need is to post about more [__]
so like it's not just like the Journey
of branding it might also be like the
post that might change your business
is what it feels like to be a girl dad
what did really well was there I did out
there if you can change your business
and it like go figure right like for you
it's storytelling and that's and when
you said story like you did something
from when I first one of my businesses
that I started years ago I'm shopping at
work I started this yeah and channel 2
news did an interview yeah I was able to
dig it up and post it yeah and we
actually did you talk yeah because it
was on the free I got it yeah yeah of
course um
you have no idea how many people reached
out oh [__] Vic you had black hair and
you know Nick the other thing the other
thing you haven't done is you haven't
played with him so you posted it what
about doing a split screen like I do
where you play 13 seconds from it and
then do two minutes of your observation
of it right you know what would be a
mate one of the things I love about
having a library is in 20 years making
content where I'm telling you what was
in my mind at the time or what I didn't
tell you at the time or couldn't tell
you at the time or didn't understand at
the time
so I also think story time with you
would be huge as someone who has like
Gift of Gab and like I sense your energy
just what I would do if I were you is I
would tell stories of big mistakes
notice
but like I love telling the story of
passing on Uber twice because I
overextended myself on an apartment and
see the one time I overextended myself
and didn't live my thesis it bit me in
the ass because I would have made 500
million on Uber if I invested normally
like I always did like you you've got
plenty of Stories of the and I've always
wanted and I'm probably at that point in
my career and you definitely are I think
the best series that an OG can do is 20
part series on things I said no to that
cost me
because most business people say no too
much
right and so like if you can think about
like
and like this is where it gets fun this
is where maybe like two two grand
marnies on a rocks make you remember
[__] you forgot about yeah like you know
like you know what I think a lot about I
think a lot about the meanings I didn't
take and how they could have been the
meeting
and sometimes you just don't even know
but sometimes you do know and so like
there's some things to talk about there
yeah okay that's fantastic thank you you
got it all right answer
um so so far lots of great nuggets to
safer through
um so my background is I was a footwear
designer for 17 years I worked for
Beyonce I worked for Kenneth Cole I've
done all this great product and actually
that Joe's wife is uh in the Footwear
Biz as well
um and so coming up with this company
um my joke is always that I have a
landfill out there with my name on it I
was building all this great product I
was building product for Costco and
Payless and Marshalls and TJ Maxx and I
found myself in this position of like
what now like I've been doing this for
so long and I'm not feeling passionate
about it anymore and happy circumstance
ended up in a masters for sustainability
and had a taskrabbit come to my
apartment they helped me go through my
closet and they pulled out this bag and
they're like what is this and I was like
oh that's alterations I have to do and
they're like are you gonna do them I was
like and
so I you know I ended up donating them
and I I looked back at that I'm like
wait hold on like I'm literally in a
master's sustainability I love fashion
and that bag probably had the best
things in my closet that I had a story
for to tell and I wasn't telling it and
so I started asking people well do you
have a bag in the back of your closet
and it was either the trunk of a car the
back of a closet
um and Kate's one of our customers and
for her and I was part of that luminary
community and so we started seeing this
opportunity that every single person
here has something in their closet that
something is wrong with whether it's a
tear or a button anything so how do we
solve that problem so for the customers
I've asked you that so smart thank you
for small businesses you have Mom and
Pop shops who are being totally you know
broken by this technology that's helped
air and and travel and all these things
but they're left behind so my question
is going to be small Brands customers
brand easy we're taking their budget
dollars for sustainable initiatives and
effectively using them to badge them
with local tailors so Macy's you buy
something in New York but let's say you
bought it online and you live in
Kentucky how are they connecting you
with a tailor or a cobbler in your
location that you can connect with and
so finally the planet we you know if you
can extend the life of your clothes by
just a few months you can actually
increase your decrease your carbon
footprint by 20 to 30 percent all that
to say I have these four main
stakeholders and I love them all so much
and we're about to start our pre-seed
fundraise and I my co-founder her
background's engineering Consulting
she's worked for luxury Brands and data
and analytics and I'm the
I talked for a long time and I love what
I do and I'm so happy and excited
um how do I most effectively speak to
these four stakeholders speak to
investors and
create that road map for them because
like my real vision is reinvigorating
the industry through certifications and
trainings and making it so sexy to
repair or revive your wardrobe that
we're actually taking these tale these
designers out of school who are
absolutely like I literally had no idea
this is what designing was and giving
them the opportunity to work directly
with people and learn from these like
skilled Artisans who are not passing
down their their work understood
with the purpose in the short term to
raise Capital yes
so
um I think that in the short term
there's only two ways that you would do
that one is go bananas on you being the
face of the brand and doing content
or two you going through an exercise
similar to the last one of I do not
think business people realize that
almost all the gold is in their iPhone
contacts from A to Z
to me like when I think about notice how
like you just gave the beautiful like
statement and the nicest thing anyone's
ever seen no it's real it's real it's
the reason I gave you the answer of
maybe you should be making a lot of
content I think it would go well yeah
but notice how when I got to speak after
all of that I just went right to the
punch line which is like right now you
need capital and so I go to yes I could
tell you to start making unlimited tick
tocks in LinkedIn in seven months you'd
probably get inquiries
ask you to make a video or six so
they're not all the same and be like hey
friend I'm actually texting this to
about 20 30 of my friends on my cell
phone to tell you like what I'm up to
but if you if you give me three minutes
just watch this and you make like four
different versions because obviously
from A to Z you have the people you talk
to often
then you have tier two
then you have tier three they haven't
talked to in six months to a year but
you kind of know and then tier four
you're like I'm not even sure if I know
this person right yeah you kind of need
to make a video for all of them and
literally what's your grandma yay water
wine coffee what do you drink
fair enough same literally if you're
raising capital I think it's in your
phone
like literally follow-up question please
um I have been building this brand for
the last I apologize for a second and so
for like all of you
literally the video is like and again
four groups homies
kind of homies
know them pretty solid but haven't
talked in a year I have no [__] idea
who this is and making four different
videos and literally for you it's like
hey I'm just doing business development
I hope you've been well like because
remember the first 13 seconds for those
four groups are going to be very
different yeah
hey the fourth one hey how you been
yeah
is doing some Karma out here what you
know want to tell you what I've been up
to what I want which is I want some
customers on my [__] hit me back with
what you're up to maybe I can help you
just some Karma
that's gonna Land
versus you know versus your first group
we're gonna text and be like hey I made
this video for like my 25 closest
friends watch it because you know you
can get away with that with that video
anyway keep going
so I've been building this for the last
couple years and luckily I like thrive
in the awkward and I'm ha like I have
the Goldfish Memory like I keep going
but what we built was a mobile tailoring
company and what we saw was that it's
really labor intensive and asset heavy
and so I've always thought of it like I
have a quota to reach with with my
friends and I through the pandemic we
built a New York City face mask
initiative we built we made 40 000 masks
for Frontline providers using tailors
because we were supposed to launch the
company on March 20th 20 20.
um but it was really it was an amazing
like of course I wouldn't change it yeah
I've had like happiness what is this
community and the family I've built
here's the interesting thing that now I
finally I'm like I get it I know what
I'm doing and I feel like I've tapped
like you've tapped everyone yeah and I I
do you're gonna annoy people but I also
I'm like no I've got it now come back
tell them the truth make different
videos
you know that your best homie you've
actually like truly cried wolf not only
on this project but through the years
and so that person's got to hear
something different than me who met you
once at a conference and you have my
info like here's the bottom line
what's the alternative yeah like as long
as you're empathetic in your
communication look
everything that is anytime I've ever
wanted to sell anything when empathy
launched when I had books be friends
I go into the rare occasion of
empathetic sales mode
and I go into a cocoon
sometimes a 20-hour flight
I've actually gone to our age office
once because I had to work for 10
straight hours and didn't think I could
do it any other way besides taking a
flight Asia that's how hard it is to
sometimes get into the zone for some of
us other people I really put I've never
done this actually that's not true when
I had to do V friends I knew that I had
to draw 250 people I literally rented uh
actually that's not true one of Mona's
friends had a house in Malibu's I come
and stay and I went for a week with five
or six of the crew and just drew just
was creative
this is the biggest thing you're working
on you have to go off the grid and ask
everybody from A to Z again in context
maybe for you with 700 videos because
every one of the people you've annoyed
needs their own individual I'm serious
yeah and that's okay yeah because here's
my question what's the alternative this
is the worst fundraising market we've
had yeah in forever yeah the end you're
not gonna it's so hard to raise Capital
if you're going to raise Capital the
terms are going to be obnoxiously bad
yeah so you have the option of getting a
huge waste of time with [__] VCS
that won't give you the money anyway
right or you go back to the well but you
go but notice maybe you've been on the
kick up group one and two
you never know in group three and four I
mean when I tell you in my group one and
I'm a giver I've had people who I've
like changed the rep I'll just paint you
a very clear picture when I go to sell
books
four that I've talked to Once forget
about me being Gary B I'll take it back
seven or eight years ago where I was
like garyvee but like not this garyvee
right like nobody did it because I was
cool they kind of knew me a little
something I had people who I barely knew
bought 50 books just because they're
like me and they're on some karma [__]
and they're like I got you I people in
group one who I got them I would one
person as you can see the passion's
coming through
one person I went to bat for on an
investment re
-round to get them in it was closed I
put like I went out of my way he put in
50k and made 13 million dollars on that
exit and he bought zero books
yeah and I was and when I tell you I'm
still very friendly person that doesn't
even register yeah I go into empathy
like baby was busy maybe you didn't see
it I did hit him up four times
because I thought it was because I
thought it was gonna be a big one
because like this man made a lot of
money he's gonna buy a thousand books
like I really took it like you know and
and and you know some people don't see
the world the same way like I was
mortified when I found out six years
into traveling that you're supposed to
leave a tip for people at the hotel
that was one of the worst days of my
life in my entire life one of the worst
days was somewhere around mid-30s
somehow I don't even remember now I was
like what you know because I didn't grow
up traveling I didn't know I didn't I
never heard of it I didn't know it was
like the worst feeling ever in my
stomach because I was very passionate
about tipping and I just sometimes you
don't know the etiquette yeah like you
know so like I was like well who am I to
judge this person I didn't know that
every time I was in a hotel I should
leave something I just didn't know I
knew if for a driver I knew for someone
taking out a package I just didn't know
yeah maybe he doesn't know if someone
makes you 13 million dollars you should
buy something you know
um this why am I telling you that's so
long-winded
you got to reset and you got to go with
what's reality for you and my one
follow-up question again is in terms of
accredited investors I've done my
research safe notes on this and what are
you looking for and that's the one thing
it's like if you want to end up in a VC
and at some point we'll probably end up
in like a circular VC for circular
economy
but we don't want to do it now we want
to do precede we want Angel Investors we
want friends and family but some of my
friends are like how and I I've thought
about crowdfunding and it's like all
these questions of what's the best way
to fundraise and you're saying go to
these people do I want to go to them and
say do you know anyone who's an
accredited Professor don't worry about
the incredible everyone who's in
creditvisor knows credibester comes from
like how their financial status yeah
don't over you're getting scared of
something that doesn't matter but how do
I what if someone isn't one and wants to
invest in us your lawyer or whoever is
helping you will figure that out most
people almost no one hits that realm
because you're not asking for 500 right
you're asking for 10 15 20 000 minimum
and that's Gonna Knock most people into
that realm she can help your daddy
all right bye so um
we are in year four of the company
self-funded the business
and
um we're further ahead than I ever
thought we would be in year four thanks
to the pandemic sure totally change the
mind transform the business and we were
very nimble
I am the brand the brand is me yep um
I've heard of the concert
my struggle or I guess why I'm sitting
here and is you talk a lot about like
the posting how do you really create
capacity right so I do a post a week on
LinkedIn it gets a hundred thousand
views right amazing great fantastic
um and it's driving a conversation
because that's all I want to do it's not
selling the business it's not talking
it's about the conversation
so how you talk about you know right up
right off the top when I hear that yeah
what my immediately my Spidey senses are
like ah she hasn't realized that she is
a content creator that happens to have
this business
I think me making content is more
important than anything
you don't
because you're only posting once a week
on LinkedIn you haven't gone to that
perspective yeah of holy [__] this is
that important which is wildly easy to
not see yeah I get it because I'm old
enough to know where this sits you know
for a 20 year old coming up the game
like this is like such a big deal like
it's like the framework and then but for
a lot of us in this room that did
business before this world existed the
thought of being a Content like that's
always sounded like a side dish but it's
the main dish now
you like me okay yes I figured it out
that it was the main dish but I do 15
hours a day work with no content
creation right
what you need to figure out is the next
part of like how are you going to make
yourself make content so then because
it's the most important thing I was like
I'm gonna hire people to work on this
when you think it's the most important
thing you're not scared to spend a
hundred thousand dollars a year on two
people okay right like for me and people
like well Gary a lot of my friends like
that's a lot I'm like how much money are
you making what do you want to
accomplish like you know all of a sudden
like I underpaint that for to this hour
I underpay my salary at my companies
because I want the money to keep feeding
the company right right and so but again
and then it gets really interesting all
of a sudden you start how many employees
you have uh 22.
I am positive on my [__] heart the
19th 20th 21st and 22nd most important
person in the company if they're not
doing something that nobody else does if
they're a second person or a third
person or a fourth person that does what
the others do
a true content on you
person is more valuable than those four
so it's either a little less take-home
yeah on the p l or if you're like Gary
you don't get it I'm like a bare minimum
and I need this for to sustain My
Lifestyle great well that's not the case
hire two people right so I guess hire
the two people I guess we're you know
you talk about more and these young
people nobody else that work for 28 an
hour yep they do okay they can help me
because I'll help you ready make a video
yep post it on LinkedIn of the feelings
you have about this and find listen a
lot of these kids are right and a lot of
these kids are right I know like when
somebody says to me [__] you Gary you're
paying minimum wage I'm like I get it I
get them I'm like you have an ideology
that's from scarcity or abundance it's
one of those too but I'm like but you do
understand like this really works for
some people yeah and like I'm just
following the law
like I'll pay 90 an hour if New York
wants to make that the minimum I'm just
you know like there's a lot of [__]
people who want to get in the [__]
door here and are willing to like a lot
of us can come up with like like cool I
love when I get the emails like [__] you
from Harvard Johnny
I'm like easy for you to say Harvard
Johnny you [__] you're like like you
[__] went to private school your
whole life and went to [__] camp in
the summer instead of work at Best Buy
like and by the way and then there's the
Other Extreme that's Harvard Johnny and
then there's the other person who's like
[__] you I should be getting I get why
but they don't get to make the rules of
life nor do I I'm just living yeah I
promise you there's two people would rip
their [__] arm off there's both a
Yale 20 year old woman or 22 year old
woman Yale graduate and Street kid 22
year old that would die to work for you
for 20 bucks an hour doing social media
content both one of each and by the way
if you were building a two-person team I
would immediately build it that way give
me Yale Yale Yale Susan give me street
kid Monica work with me just to work
with you yeah that's where I have no
struggle because
you know you know because you get this I
gotta put it into the company you are
the market I know your opening line is I
am the company and the company is me
yeah a couple things yeah how long does
it take you to make that one post
roughly in your mind 20 minutes right if
that 20 minutes becomes 40 and you're
doing a podcast
you could get on if I'm on tons of
podcasts well every single one of those
you should post produce the video and
that should be your content on LinkedIn
yeah yeah she just doesn't have to she's
in she was hello
yeah I'm aware so yeah I'm more worried
about getting her in the mindset of it
notice notice how she's like I'm like
she knows who I am I assume you've seen
some of my content you're aware that my
content is post-production for me being
on podcasts right yeah all of a sudden
you can see the path of how to get to 15
pieces of content yeah
I still publicly speak
for the content yeah I do four D's right
for the content yeah I went to an army
base in New Jersey today and spoke to
them for the content content okay the
content's the reason I'm doing it and
then all the other stuff is the nice to
have where everyone perceives the nice
to have to be the thing
I don't have time for podcasts I have
time for podcasts when it gives me 24
pieces of content okay the podcast I'm
doing now are smaller than ever
because I want them to be more Niche for
Content I'm trying to get out
right a female entrepreneur is going to
ask me different questions as a dude
that like right uh a skateboard podcast
I did not too long ago I did it because
they're gonna ask me different questions
get me into a different Zone okay got it
I got it the other thing you can do is
do open q a t with garyvee and
askgaryvee are still what I really want
to be doing
so fun you're like you literally are
helping young female entrepreneurs
accomplish what you did you're just
answering four questions they're pumped
I do it all day long exactly so then
literally have one person illuminary
filming the [__] out of you okay yeah
thank you you'll have unlimited content
let's do it you're welcome it will be
massive for you you especially it's
gonna be like it's a grand slam
foreign